à mesure que l'inquiétude grandit
l'europe se referme cette semaine
plusieurs pays du vieux continent ont
pris de nouvelles mesures pour tenter de
contrer la pandémie de coronavirus comme
en espagne ou la barre symbolique des 3
millions de cas a été dépassé parmi les
mesures des autorités espagnoles le
bouclage d'une dizaine de nouvelles
villes et de régions
à madrid les réunions sont interdites
entre minuit et 6 heures du matin entre
minuit et 6h les réunions familiales ou
sociales sont limitées aux espaces
publics et privés et sont réservés aux
personnes d'un même foyer pendant le
reste de la journée
la limitation à six personnes maximale
est maintenue sauf s'il s'agit de
cohabitants en ce qui concerne
l'hôtellerie la restauration le service
de bar est suspendu en intérieur la
capacité des tables est réduite à 50% et
celle des terrasses à 75 % en italie si
le couvre feu a été instauré dans deux
régions la lombardie et la campanie la
mesure s'applique pour une durée de
trois semaines alors que le nombre de
nouveaux cas se remet à flamber à naples
le couvre-feu est déjà contesté vendredi
soir des heurts ont même éclaté entre
policiers et manifestants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la réponse la plus forte entre le
co vide en europe c'est celle de dublin
en irlande c'est un confinement total
qui a été imposée pour une période de
six semaines
depuis jeudi dernier les irlandais ne
peuvent plus éloignés de chez eux à plus
de 5 km sous peine d'amendé
il ne doit pas y avoir de rassemblements
sociaux ou familiaux dans les maisons et
les jardins les visites pour des raisons
de solidarité et à des fins de soins
pouvant se poursuivre nous avons décidé
que la participation au mariage sera
maintenu à 25 invités les restaurants
les cafés les bars seront autorisés à
proposer uniquement des services à
emporter
seuls les commerces de détail essentiel
pourront rester ouverts tout le monde
dans le pays et priées de rester chez
soi l'exercice physique étant autorisés
dans un rayon de 5 km autour de son
domicile mesures drastiques également du
côté de la république tchèque où le
gouvernement a décidé ce mercredi de
confiner tout le pays une mesure qui
s'accompagne de la fermeture des
commerces non essentiel et de
l'interdiction des regroupements de plus
de deux personnes
des annonces faites par le ministre
tchèque de la santé qui a dû
démissionner après avoir bravé les
règles sanitaires qu'il avait lui même
édictées
le gouvernement va limiter les
déplacements et les contacts avec
d'autres personnes
à l'exception des sorties pour le
travail les courses et les visites chez
le médecin de son côté l'allemagne a
elle aussi durcie ces restrictions en
ordonnant la fermeture de ces bars et de
ses restaurants dès 22h ou 23h selon les
villes à berlin le port du masque est
obligatoire dans certaines rues des
règles sanitaires strictes pour le pays
mais bien plus souple que chez la
plupart de ses voisins européens